okay are we ready I think web wait hold
on hold on hold on wait it's all green
and what do you know what do you mean
it's all green it's all green on one
side and the video was smashed on the
other side hold up Halep did you did you
update your drivers doing you too yeah
dude dude you gotta update your drivers
stuff doesn't work if you don't update
the drivers sorry about that let's do
that now hello mutant league we've
realized that throughout the entire time
we've been providing with updates we
haven't actually taken you on a bit of a
tour of true golf / Big Finish games so
we have take you throughout the officers
here or studios as we like to refer to
them and show you and introduce you to
some of the key members who are working
really hard to bring test or affect to
life so let's go for a bit of a walk
this is chris kelly he's a lead
programmer of tesslar effects hey what
up what up so Chris you supa palms about
the yellow ya popped x what else he is
extremely passionate and I really like
his choice of music I'm going to see
where we're testing at some of the
pirate techniques they're using the game
second
this is where the magic happens here
this is the video workstation where
basically all the video comes together
and as you can see it's got more screens
than minority report at the moment and
this pleased here that is 30 whole
terabytes of uncompressed 2k video right
there delivering Tesla effect in the
highest fidelity possible let's just say
it's going to kick some major butt when
it finally makes it to your screens Oh
everyone this is that this is Gordon you
just started working for us so say hi
good hi we're gonna take you to meet
Mick flame who actually works here at
true golf c IJ j as some of you are
aware played the character of McFlynn in
under a Killing Moon and he is our
wonderful IT department here the only IT
department here this is mr. Doug van der
grift mr. Brian Johnson and mr. Matt
lovins there a lot department and
animation departments and they're doing
a fantastic job you got super pumped
about the final game super pumped
everybody have a great time playing this
game because we had a great time
building it and you know we can't leave
until we see Doug vandagriff do his rook
for us so mr. Murphy
you
got it hey we're working on cool yeah
that's what that's why you know you're
there and not behind the cam man that's
why I'm saying gotta plug it in so man
how do you feel about the game we are
here working on the game working on the
music finishing it up I can't believe
it's been two years and it's all coming
down to like this big moment at the end
and it sounds really good and really
proud of what what's kind of come
together and yeah it's fantastic it is
epic you guys are going to be your socks
are gonna be knocked off with what
Bobby's down but even if you were in
shoes like you're going to go home and
take your shoes off and realize whether
my socks go cuz I was knocked off hey
everyone thanks for checking out the
latest Tesla effect update as you just
seen everyone's burning the midnight oil
to make our new tex murphy product the
most incredible adventure game ever we
feel that the Tesla effect will
absolutely blow away adventure players
but will also appeal to game players as
a whole what we've achieved with our
Kickstarter program will stun the gaming
community and make our supporters look
like heroes to all who enjoy rich
multipath storytelling and totally
immersive gameplay now I know we'd
announced our launch date is april
twenty second but in order to make sure
this game is as clean and tight as it
can be we've talked to Atlas our
publisher and we move the date 2 mae7 I
know if you'll indulge us and give us a
little extra time to put all the shine
we can on Tesla this text product will
be a dazzling example of how great the
adventure genre can be we're rapidly
approaching the finish line and I know
you'll be thrilled at the results thanks
again for your help and support and
putting Tex Murphy back in the saddle
again
you